هذه الصور الان نبثها على الهواء
هشام من غزه قبل قليل على ما يبدو انها
تظهر مكانا تم استهدافه في احدى الغارات
الغارتين الاخيرتين اللتين قامت بهما قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي سواء في حي الشجاعيه
او في منطقه
اليرموك هناك كان تواجد لسياره اسعاف
يشاهدها الان وتجمع لعدد من المدنيين ثم
استمعنا لصوت انفجار سياتي بعد قليل اذا
في هذه الصوره هناك عناصر الدفاع المدني
عدد من المدنيين ومن ثم صوت انفجار شديد
الذي هي الصور التي توفرت لديك هشام وهي
نعم الصوره لدي وشاهدتها قبل قليل وهي
بالفعل في منطقه اليرموك التي تعرضت لقصف
تعرض فيها منزل القصف في تلك المنطقه وكما
تحدثنا فان القصف بدا من طائره استطلاع
اسرائيليه وبالتالي
عندما يحدث القصف هذا يؤكد من خلال هذه
الصوره ان المواطنين لا يكون لديهم اي علم
في اي منطقه يحدث القصف هناك كان تجمهر
للمواطنين وهذا ربما يرجح بوجود عدد من
الاصابات جراء هذا القصف الذي استهدف
منزلا في منطقه اليرموك في وسط مدينه غزه
وطواقم الدفاع المدني حضرت الى المكان بعد
قصف هذه
القصف هذا المنزل
بصاروخ من طائره استطلاع ربما وبعد ذلك تم
قصفه من الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه
وكما تحدثت فان هذا الصاروخ هو ص غريب
لاول مره نشهد صواريخ تطلقها الطائرات
الحربيه الاسرائيليه لا تنبعث منها السنت
للهب او اصوات انفجارات كبيره وهي المره
الثانيه على الاقل التي تستخدمها الطائرات
الحربيه الاسرائيليه في هكذا قصف
وتستخدمها في قصف المنازل خاصه تلك
المنازل التي تتعرض للقصف وتعرضت هذه
الليله منزلين على الاقل القصف منزل في حي
الشجاعيه شرق مدينه غزه قصف بذات الطريقه
واشتعلت النيران ايضا فيه وعمل الطواقم
الدفاع المدني وسيارات الاسعاف على اطفاء
الحريق الذي اشتعل ونشب في هذا في هذه في
تلك الشق السكنيه التي استهدفت منزل ابو
العطا وهو منزل الشهيد القائد بهاء ابو
العطا القائد في سرايا القدس الجناح
العسكري اللي حركه الجهاد الاسلامي والذي
اغتالته اسرائيل في العام 2019 بذا
الطريقه التي تستهدف فيها هذه الايام قاده
سرايا القدس الجناح العسكري لحركه الجهد
الاسلامي
وقبل قليل
بذات الطريقه استهدفت اسرائيل
هذه هذا المنزل في منطقه اليرموك لم نشعر
بصوت انفجار ولم نستمع الى صوت انفجار لم
نشعر بالصاروخ ولم نشهد السنه للذهب او
اعمده للدخان وهذا ربما يشير الى نوع جديد
من الصواريخ التي تستخدمها الطائرات
الحربيه الاسرائيليه في قصف هذه
الشقق ومنازل السكنيه المدنيه تحدث لا
تحدث اصوات لا تحدث اي اشارات ان هناك قصف
ومن ثم تشتعل النيران في هذه المنازل نحن
نتحدث عن قصف عنيف مدمر وكما ترين في
الصوره
المواطنين كان يتواجدون في تلك المنطقه
ولم نستمع من خلال واثناء تواجدهم الى صوت
كبير او صوت ضخم انفجار ضخم في كل المرات
وكل التصعيد والحروب السابقه كان القصف
يحدث انفجارا كبيرا يحدث دمارا هائلا يحدث
نيران ترتفع في السماء والسنه اللهب
تتصاعد والسنه اللهب تتصاعد واعمده الدخان
ايضا تتصاعد لكن في هذه المره وهذه الليله
اسرائيل تستخدم صواريخ مختلفه نوعا ما عن
تلك التي كانت تستخدمها في حروب ماضيه
وحروب سابقه
والان حتى الان ما زالت طواقم الدفاع
المدني وسيارات الاسعاف وطواقم الاسعاف
تتواجد بالقرب من هذا المنزل وهناك دائما
تخوف من عوده اسرائيل
لقصف هذه المنازل مره اخرى اثناء تواجدها
الطواقم الدفاع المدني وقد شهدنا هذه
الحوادث اكثر اكثر من مره في حروب س